[Music]
appears to be a standard sequence
violation
branch is growing at a stable rate and
slope
variant identified i beg your pardon
on behalf of the time variance authority
i hereby arrest you for crimes against
the sacred timeline
hands up you're coming with us
i'm sorry who's us
last chance variant
[Laughter]
it's been a very long day and i think
i've had my fill of idiots in armoured
suits telling me what to do so
if you don't mind this is actually your
last chance
now get out of my way
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said
what
sign this too
oh this is absurd
and this
[Music]
huh
i'm agent mobius by the way
are you taking me somewhere to kill me
no that's where you just were
i'm taking you someplace to talk but i
don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did because we both know you
love to talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tba
what does that mean you'll catch up
so you're part of the tva's courageous
and dedicated workforce
yes you were created by the timekeepers
to protect the sacred timeline correct
is that funny the idea that your little
club decides the fate of trillions of
people across all of existence at the
behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
i thought you didn't like to talk
laughing varian l1130
aka loki laupisson is charged with
sequence
violation 720.89
how do you plead
madam a god doesn't plead look this has
been a very enjoyable pantomime but i'd
like to go home now
are you guilty or not guilty sir
guilty of being the god of mischief yes
guilty of finding all this incredibly
tedious yes
guilty of a crime against the sacred
timeline absolutely not you have the
wrong person
okay you're in a lot of trouble what do
you want from me
come on sit down our timeline is in
chaos
and you need the goddess mischief to
help you loki is unpredictable
i know what i am good
bad
[Music]
bit of both original series streaming
wednesday june 9th
only on disney plus
[Music]
you